I am dying to know about reuniting with
Mimi on this lately different material
so is there any side of her that you saw
on this she became a monster on this no
no it's exactly the same as you would
expect I mean it's that thing of you
know the family broke up for the show
and then very shortly thereafter I did
see her again which is wonderful and how
was it working with felicity because she
is just a powerhouse in this movie and
in particular her courtroom speech I
said she monster you know it's like it's
it's the Mount Everest of speeches and
we were all very curious to see you know
cuz we shot that later in the movie and
we were curious to see how the hell she
because none of us would have wanted to
do that speech and man she just banged
it right out of park she she nailed it
what's it like for you while she's
performing that speech are you all just
actually sitting in there are they
capturing that for multiple angles where
you don't have to be there no we were
all there it was supposed to be shot I
think in four days and I think we did it
in half the time because she never once
went up forgot her lines flubbed Sheba
and she also did it for all the coverage
too so you know even they're doing an
insert on a clock you know she's still
doing the speech the full thing not just
like you know a little chunk of it and a
little piece of it you know she she must
have done it hundreds of times you had
such a colorful character here so I
wanted to know about figuring out how to
kind of peg how big to go with him and
when to rein it in you know I mean we
sort of we didn't have I I wasn't able
to locate the guy because he's one of
the least photographed men on the planet
and we didn't know what he looked like
we didn't know what the you know you
know what his I didn't know what is
there was no film or footage that I
could base it on so I really relied on
the material obviously it's just just
the dramatic effect that I that me and
Mimi sort of figured out it needed and
then and then you know it was just you
know I I sort of had to pick a lane and
so I've decided to play and now clearly
he's a passionate guy who works with you
very smart bright man and had to just
sort of just take a swing in took a big
swing and it's like just the right
amount of color I love that character
pops dude I am fascinated by preset
routines and rituals so what do you have
to do before you hit a set for work what
do I have you know I think it a lot of
it happens before you get to the set I
I'm a big believer in breaking down your
script sort of understanding what you're
gonna be shooting on what day and what
you have to be prepared for and and to
be as prepared as possible before you
get to the set you know there's nothing
not the case on it with any of these
people in this film we play a game on
collider called would you rather and one
of the questions on there is would you
rather work with an actor who prepares
way too much or not enough way too much
yeah how question I mean I wouldn't even
know I don't working with actors who
don't prepare is infuriating I think
this is a movie that is going to make a
big difference for a lot of people out
there and personally it definitely
inspired me to remember stick to what
you know what you believe in what you
love and keep fighting for it so having
made this movie and essentially lived in
it for the entire shooting process is
there anything you took away from the
experience that you found really
inspiring
maybe so I mean I would expect the
pleasure of you know seeing me me work
for a long time now and and she's always
been very inspiring I keep looking for
the connective tissue between her and
Ruth Bader Ginsburg because there is
connective tissue you know she was a
woman who with enormous talents who I
think was unfairly sort of kicked out of
Hollywood after a film didn't perform as
well she where I don't come in would
have been kicked out but through hard
work and also doing some things that she
didn't necessarily want to do was able
to sort of get back into it it's a
disappointment because she could have
made some wonderful films
that we'll never see because that time
is gone Ruth Bader Ginsburg is similar
in that you know she spent a lot of
years not practicing law because she
couldn't get hired now I don't know how
she could beat being in the Supreme
Court she could maybe gotten there 20
years sooner um but you know I think
it's both women that are a lesson and
that's in the working of it and in the
story of Ruth Bader Ginsburg are a
lesson in just keep working at what you
do one step is a step ten steps or ten
steps and just keep and work hard you
know and nothing will be handed to you
you have to sometimes go together that's
why that was my takeaway that was
beautifully said
you